well my my wife's sister my
sister-in-law case you don't know that's
the way that relationship works just
just had a baby so my wife went away for
a few days she went she was away over
the weekend it's to help with with the
baby she took our youngest kid with her
but she left me with the twins and it's
not the first it's not the first time
I've had the kids by myself for an
extended period of time
and I'm not one of those dads that can't
figure out how to take care of his own
kids I don't have that problem I think
those dads mostly exist in sitcoms but
the one problem I do run into and this
is the one area where I guess I am like
the clueless stereotypical dad from the
sitcom but the thing is I don't know why
it is but I can't I can't figure out how
to find anything in my own house I don't
know where anything is in my own house
and I've had this problem for as long as
I've been alive I mean even but when I
was a kid and I lived in my parents
house all those years I never knew where
anything was and and and now in my own
house I don't know where anything is and
usually it's not a problem because my
wife is here so if I'm looking for
something I'm looking for a pair of
scissors I can just ask her where the
scissors and she'll say oh well they're
in the same place they were the last 18
times us and then I'll say what well
okay but what where were they then and
then she'll explain so and we have that
conversation you know prog in a
conversation like that approximately 30
to 40 times a day but when she's not
around and I'm looking for something
what am I supposed to do you know I can
text her which I do but she doesn't
always respond promptly so now I have
been reduced or I can Google like in the
average house where does this item
because I can do that
but what I've been reduced it was right
now I asked my five-year-old daughter
where things are in the house and sadly
enough she actually knows and will tell
me so I have my five daughter now
telling me in the right direction am I
in the house so yesterday at various
different points she was able to bail me
out
and correctly locate a pair of scissors
I don't know why I always need scissors
but I I for some reason I'm constantly
needing them and I'm never knowing where
they are but she found a pair of
scissors
her brothers sneakers her brother socks
an extra blanket a box of crayons all
those things she could find not that I
needed those for related reasons but at
various different points so that's been
good she Inge and she likes to be the
mommy of the house even when the real
mommy is here and when the real mommy is
not here then she really wants to step
in and and and do that so I don't you
know I don't really mind like yesterday
I I had her brother go upstairs to clean
his room and when he called down and
said said daddy I finished the room
my daughter shouted up did you just
stuff everything under the blanket I'm
gonna go up there and check and I said
yeah could you go up there and check
actually it'd be easier for me if you
were just going so it's good it's nice
having a helper round it's it's that's
why it's good to have a daughter around
this I don't know if I just had a bunch
of sons and we were left alone in the
house I don't know what we would be we
wouldn't be able to find anything all
right
anyway so two things I want to touch on
today first of all unrelated but two to
two things I want to talk about first of
all perhaps you witnessed some of the
theatrics surrounding Cavanaugh's
confirmation this weekend if you happen
to turn on the news you would have seen
it
leftists were losing their mind as usual
nothing nothing new about that as we
have seen any time there's a mob of
people throwing a hissy fit it is almost
always a leftist mob I don't know if
you've noticed that but it is almost
always if there's a riot if there are
people screaming in the street if there
are people burning down buildings
turning over cop cars whatever it is
destruction of property man you fool
themselves it's almost always left
that's the one exception the one
exception I can think of in recent
history would be the one or two white
nationalist rallies that we've seen and
really really only just the one in there
was really the one that was big and
chaotic so that's one one exception
aside from those it's always leftist but
the one thing the one image that kind of
stands out from this past weekend
in terms of the protests especially is
the image of the people I don't know if
you saw this but there are people
literally after the cough after Kavanagh
was officially confirmed there are
people literally clawing at the doors of
the Supreme Court it was like something
out of The Walking Dead you're these
people screaming just these gutter all
kind of unhuman sounding demonically
possessed screams while they were
clawing at the doors of the Supreme
Court I mean some of them are trying to
knock that they were running into the
door trying to knock it over doors which
by the way look to be made of stone and
probably weigh a couple tons apiece but
in their impotent rage they thought they
could break down the doors or claw them
open and to what end I'm not sure I do
they think that the Supreme Court
justices actually live inside the
Supreme Court building is that what they
think do they think that that we keep
them all they're like cryogenically
frozen and then we thaw them out for
every session I think that might
actually be the case with Ruth Bader
Ginsburg but but generally these people
live in homes I don't know what even if
you could manage to claw open a stone
door I don't know what you think that
would accomplish I'm not sure but it
really is it's it's we can laugh about
it we have to laugh about it right
because number one it's hilarious but
number two what else are you gonna do
but as we're laughing we have to
recognize that this is real I mean
they're these are real people who are
behaving this way and this is not
uncommon anymore
we've gotten to the point where we can
no longer say what's an aberration it's
just a few of them this is very common
at any time things don't go the way left
this want whether it's an election
Supreme Court confirmation a grand jury
you know a trial of a cop accused of
shooting somebody whatever it is
whatever news whatever item in the news
they don't like this is how they respond
every time it's not an exaggeration and
as we've watched this spectacle unfold
and we have heard
left is more than one leftist promise to
continue with these kinds of scenes
promise to confront their opponents
everywhere including where they eat and
sleep I've seen this there you know this
is not just Maxine Waters who said
something like this this is a very
common thing now on the left where they
say well we're gonna confront
Republicans anywhere everywhere we you
know we have to be ruthless I saw
someone on Twitter today so we gonna be
ruthless towards them they shouldn't be
allowed any moment of peace out in
public so again this isn't these these
are not this is not a fringe thing this
is now this is now the approach and the
attitude of leftist in the mainstream
but as we see all of this I think that
we as conservatives have to decide how
we're gonna respond and in my view I
know there are some people who worry
that conservatives that it will have a
radicalizing effect on conservatives and
as we see this we're going to be
radicalized in response to their radical
behavior and I know there are some
people who worry that that will happen I
on the other hand hope that it will
happen it should have a radicalizing
effect and when I say radicalizing I
mean we should be radically opposed to
the leftist agenda and radically
committed to making sure that they do
not come into power we should be radical
about that that's what I mean by radical
I think now is a time for radicalism and
not the kind of radical as you see on
the Left where there crawl clawing at
doors and burning down buildings and
that kind of thing I'm not talking about
that where you're embarrassing yourself
in public or you're destroying property
of people who really have nothing to do
with it anyway not that kind of radical
I'm talking about being firm in our
convictions and absolutely unwilling to
compromise with these people who want
nothing more than the utter and total
complete destruction of those they
disagree with we have no choice they
hate us and they hate everything we
stand for I think that much is clear by
now there is no centrism anymore there
is no middle ground there is no moderate
there none of that exists the Gulf is
too wide I've been talking about this
for months now the Gulf is far too wide
and and I think it's important to
establish this because there are still
some people some on the right who
vision a return to compromise and a
return to civility and decency but
that's not gonna happen when you have
two sides who disagree fundamentally
about the most basic questions of life
the only way to achieve unity is for one
side or the other or both sides to
abandon their fundamental convictions
the left as we have seen will not do
that and we should not do that either I
mean look at Kavanagh this this is what
we lose sight of it I don't think we
should lose sight of this with Cavanaugh
Cavanaugh actually is a compromise he
represents compromise he is not nearly
as far right as some of the other
options would have been there were other
people there were people on the list
like Amy Barrett for instance who would
have been far more to the right than
then Cavanaugh he's actually he's pretty
moderate he's so moderate that it's not
even guaranteed that he would vote to
overturn Roe I think I think I mean it's
at least 50/50 whether or not he would
even cast that vote if given the chance
I think we can be sure that he won't
vote to strengthen abortion protections
and we can be pretty sure that he won't
vote to restrict religious liberty any
more than it is and and so forth but
would he be in favor of something as
severe as overturning Roe that is by no
means a given so again with Cavanaugh
Republicans compromised they said to the
left okay we're in power we can put in
there whoever we want to put in there
but we're gonna be fair and so we'll put
in somebody who is who was closer to the
center than he is to Scalia right that's
what they did
and what how did the left respond they
took this moderate justice and they
ripped him apart and they feasted on his
innards like zombies that's what they
did nothing but complete and total
capitulation will satisfy them that is
the only thing they want they nothing
but that will satisfy so we have to
decide are we going to completely and
totally capitulate to appease them
because that's the only appeal way
to appease them if we're interested in
appeasing them or will we dig in and
stand our ground and refuse to give even
an inch those are only two choices there
what I'm saying is the left has if there
was ever any choice of an in-between a
middle a compromise the left has made
that now impossible they are not leaving
that option open so you have to choose
one or the other it really is black or
white and and I think that the latter
should be our choice we should dig in
and stand our ground and refuse to give
an inch and thus be radical radicalized
it's our only choices it's the only
choice they left open to us it's either
that or join them in their insanity and
their moral depravity and their nihilism
and their self-centeredness and
everything else okay that's the first
thing switching gears I would be I would
be remiss if if I were not to say happy
Columbus Day today because it is
Columbus Day and this it's not really a
totally unrelated topic actually because
talking about leftist insanity part of
the the leftist insanity we have today
is where we're told that we cannot
celebrate our our our heroes we cannot
honor those who built the civilization
that we all now live in and enjoy living
in and prefer living in perfectly but we
all prefer this civilization to any
other civilization on the globe
currently or really to any other
civilization civilization that has ever
existed on the globe we all prefer this
one if we were given a time machine and
told that we can live anywhere at any
point in history I think we would all
probably choose right now which is not
to say that right now is perfectly
wonderful and we don't have serious
problems we do but when it comes down to
it when given the choice I you know I
don't think we're gonna choose to go
anywhere else and we have our ancestors
to thank for that
pioneers explorers discoverers settlers
founders we have we have them to thank
for but the but the left says we cannot
thank them we have to
eat them and despise them and so they're
gonna spend today screaming about a
fictional version of history where
Europeans introduced rape pillage and
slavery to the peaceful and noble
inhabitants of the new world but of
course it would it would have been
impossible for the Europeans to
introduce rape pillage and slavery to an
Indian culture where rape pillage and
slavery were totally commonplace and had
been for centuries
so you you notice something about these
self-hating white guilt ridden people
you notice that they would never suggest
that the brutality of many Indian tribes
should somehow outweigh whatever they
accomplished even their propensity for
cannibalism
we're told must be understood within the
kind with in the historical and cultural
context yet somehow the sins of the
Europeans or the alleged sins in some
cases automatically negate what the
European explorers achieved and
discovered have you noticed that so with
with everybody else in history with all
other cultures with all other people we
have to have there's got to be a
historical context cultural conduct we
have to put it all into perspective but
when it comes to Europeans they're the
only one so we have to take we have to
take from from from their point in
history and bring them into the modern
world and judge them by modern standards
they're the only ones we do that to and
not only that we don't even it's it's
not just that we judge we're talking
about Columbus here specifically for a
minute it's not just that we judge him
by the moral standards of modern society
but even more absurd we judge him by the
by the technological standards of modern
society so that's where you get some of
the dumbest objections to Columbus
someone will say for instance what but
Columbus didn't even mean to discover
America well of course he didn't mean to
discover America he didn't know what
existed nobody did how could they know
and why does it matter that he didn't
mean to discover what does that mean
think about it in the future if a team
of
intrepid astronauts were to set out on a
manned mission to to Europa a moon of
Jupiter and when they get there they
were to discover a different moon one
that we didn't know about and one that
has primitive microbial life on it it
would be one of the great discover maybe
the greatest scientific discovery in the
history of humankind but would we laugh
at them and say bust those idiots didn't
even mean to discover that moon you here
look at these morons they meant to go to
you're open said they found this other
moon that happens to have life on it and
it changes the course of human society
but these idiots they didn't even mean
to discover them how did you guys didn't
even know that moon was there morons is
that what we would do or would we
celebrate their enormous achievement in
achievement that was only possible
because they had the guts and the wit
and the tenacity to get into it to get
into the - the ship in the first place
and traverse that great expanse of
nothingness at great and great risk to
themselves and only upon making that
voyage were they able to make this
discovery in the first place oh but but
Columbus never set foot on North America
did you know that and I think the people
that raised these objections I think
their first point and raising the
objection is just to say hey I know this
piece of historical information did you
know this look at this historical
information that I know hey did you know
that that Columbus didn't set foot in
North America meanwhile they just they
just learned that through a facebook
meme yesterday and now they're say hey
did you guys know well that's a stupid
objection to okay he never set foot on
North America so what he still
discovered the Caribbean islands plus
Central and South America is that not
enough
is that really not enough do you fault
him for not discovering the entire
Western Hemisphere this idiot didn't
even discover the entire Western
Hemisphere he only discovered most of it
again going to the astronaut analogy
that that's like if we finally landed on
Mars and then you go that's lame we
didn't even land on Venus laying around
Mars what about Venus he didn't even set
foot on Venus and I'm like my other
favor
objection is when somebody says well the
fight the Vikings got here first did you
know that and again this is just this is
just them showing off that they have
about one sentence worth of knowledge of
this of this period of history in fact
it's not even that period of history
because in fact the Vikings were
exploring a completely different and
much smaller expanse of ocean way up in
the North Atlantic they were exploring a
500 years before a completely different
area than a much much smaller area it is
not nearly as impressive that they were
able to traverse that small sliver of
ocean not nearly as impressive as as
Columbus making this many thousands of
miles journey across the Atlantic and
besides how do the achievements of the
Vikings undermine the achievements of
Columbus that's what I don't understand
how do the explorations of the Vikings
500 years earlier in any way detract
from what Columbus did why are we who
who cares it's so I mean if you want to
celebrate Leif Eriksson I think Leif
Eriksson days is coming up is it isn't
it like tomorrow I think maybe I'm wrong
about that but if you want to celebrate
Leif Eriksson celebrate Leif Eriksson
great I'll celebrate them with you why
do we have to they're not mutually
exclusive it's not like you have to
choose one ancient Explorer to celebrate
and then all the others we have to say
are idiots in comparison but that's not
the way this works someone today on
Twitter someone said someone said well
you know big deal that the Chinese and
the Polynesians they were explorers too
you know okay so what they explored the
Pacific Columbus explored the Atlantic
how do any of these groups detract from
the others it's like if somebody were to
cure cancer and then you go
yeah well Jonas Salk developed the polio
vaccine in nineteen
fifty-five okay great that that's one
great achievement here's another one
they're both great but of course the
biggest objection the most common
objection to Columbus is this idea that
Columbus was a was a genocide Ulm a niak
who came to the new world hoping to
pillage and enslave a peaceful people
and it's true of course that some of the
Indians he encountered were peaceful but
we have obviously taken this image of
the peaceful Indian and we have
stretched it and turned it into this
really ridiculous caricature because
they were not all peaceful it and and in
fact peace did not reign across the new
world it was a it was a violent violent
place also bear in mind that there was a
tribe called the Caribes and they rained
terror on the region where Columbus
landed these were these were violent
people who feasted on human flesh and
Columbus you know he would have heard
stories about them on his first voyage
and then he actually encountered them on
a second and in fact let me let me
briefly read just just for just for
historical edification here here's a
brief passage about the discovery or or
a run-in with these with these Caribes
this is from Admiral the Admiral of the
ocean sea by Samuel Eliot Maurice
Morrison which is which is a great great
book by the way this is someone who not
only wrote a book about Columbus's
voyages but he actually retraced those
steps and made the same voyages in an
effort to better understand what
Columbus achieved so it's a really
wonderful book but anyway this is what
it says the searching party found
plentiful evidence of these unpleasant
Carib habits which were responsible for
a new word cannibal in European
languages in the huts deserted by the
Warriors who ungallant Lee fled they
found large cuts and joints of human
flesh shin bones set aside to make
arrows of cap them up captain eyes
Arawak boy captives who are being
fattened for the griddle
and girl captives who were mainly used
to produce babies which the carobs
regarded as a particularly toothsome
morsel the search party brought in about
20 of these captives and others made
their way down to the shore and gave
themselves up voluntarily also a few
Caribes were captured by force okay so
you have the Caribes eating not only
eating children but raping other
children to produce babies who they
would then eat all right this is a kind
of thing that would go on among some
tribes in the new world now you may hear
you may hear from apologists that well
there's no archaeological evidence that
the Caribes were cannibals you may hear
that but first of all it would be
difficult it would be somewhat difficult
to find archaeological evidence of this
kind of activity 500 years later but we
do have evidence we have eyewitness
testimony we have eyewitness accounts of
these sorts of things not just from the
Spanish but from other Indian tribes who
were victimized by the Caribes so that
is evidence it's very good evidence I
think it's evidence that is conclusive
also keep something else in mind up
until very recently up until very
recently archaeologists and historians
at least modern archaeologists
historians they said they speculated
that the Spanish also fabricated or
greatly exaggerated the extent of human
sacrifice among the Aztecs and and the
Aztecs
as as we know based on what we were told
from the witnesses the Aztecs sacrificed
tens of thousands of human beings in
these McCobb rituals whether I would
tear out the beating heart roll the cut
off the limbs were all the limo's bodies
down the steps and then the limbs will
be would be feasted on by by some of the
Aztec high priests anyway for a long
time we were told that no the Spanish
they invented that they fabricated they
exaggerated well very recently like in
the last couple of years archaeologists
finally turned up
evidence of wide-scale human sacrifices
among the Aztecs they they uncovered
these racks of hundreds of human skulls
that clearly is is evidence of exactly
what the Spanish said so just bear that
when you're told oh well archeological
evidence doesn't support ya up up until
like a couple years ago they said the
same thing about the Aztecs turns out
that the Spanish we're not just making
this stuff up this is actually what
happened and they were telling us about
it but the fact that we have to deal
with when when talking about this clash
of civilizations is that rape slavery
mass murder etc all of these things were
already a normal part of life in the
Americas before the Europeans came this
was a brutal time it was brutal across
the globe for everyone everyone played
basically by the same brutal rules you
went in search of new lands and when you
found the new land you fought for it
that's the way it worked across the
globe for everybody
that's how Europeans operated that's how
the Indians operated that's how everyone
operated the world was settled and
civilized this way we may not like it it
may make our tummy hurts to think about
it we may look back on that now and say
oh they were so they they were barbaric
and maybe they were in comparison to us
in some ways but that's the way it
worked
now that doesn't excuse any one
particular atrocity but it does put
everything into perspective and I think
when we talk about Columbus Columbus
very often it seems like we divorce him
from his context and we hold him to a
standard that nobody else from his time
period has held to and that just doesn't
seem fair to me
it doesn't seem fair that Columbus is
the one single person or the Europeans
in general are the people who we hold to
this to this ridiculous standard now we
know it's it's true that Columbus was a
very flawed man but his flaws were
mostly the flaws shared by all men of
all cultures during that time and he was
also a great and gifted man and his
greatness and his gifts
were not shared by all men that's what
his flaws there was nothing there was
nothing unique or especially different
about his flaws but in terms of his
gifts and what he achieved that was
unique and that was different they took
this one particular man to do what he
did which is to sail across these
unknown waters to this unknown place and
begin the process that would eventually
result in the establishment of the
greatest civilization the world has ever
known and again I remind you it is a
civilization that we all live in and we
would prefer this civilization over any
other and I think he deserves to be
celebrated for that if you ask me he
deserves to be celebrated for that and
if we're going to say no we can't
celebrate him for that we have we have
to hate him we have to tear down the
statues we have to spit on his memory
because of the bad things that he did
they just bear in mind that we have to
do the same thing to pretty much anyone
else who lived for almost the entirety
of human civilization up until very
recently including certainly including
the the the heroes of Native American
tribes because these were also largely
brutal people who played by brutal rules
and when the Europeans came and they did
practice slavery for instance which
again doesn't justify it but the Indians
they weren't surprised by that because
that's what they did to each other that
they didn't do so this is just how the
world works
if you get you get into a fight with
another neighboring tribe or
civilization and you lose they're gonna
take you slaves this was not it was not
anything wasn't new to them they weren't
shocked by this in fact there are you
know when you read about Cortes and his
clash with the Aztecs you'll read that
in some cases the the only thing that
really shocked the Indians is it's not
that that Cortes would take prisoners or
slaves it's how humanely those prisoners
were treated keep in mind these were
people who are used to how the Aztecs
operate which is when when they took you
as a prisoner they would fatten you up
and and rip your heart out and then eat
you so that's what they were used to for
for how for how slaves and prisoners
were treated
so admittedly it wasn't a very high bar
for the Spanish to get over but they did
get over that bar at least so we have to
look at them in their historical context
and then and judge them based on that
like where was the bar set back in that
period of time and did they get over the
bar or did they fall under it or do they
basically meet the bar that I think is
the question we should ask ourselves and
I think we're gonna find for the most
part they at the very least were par you
know they very least at the very least
they were at the bar and I think in many
cases they got over it
so happy Columbus Day everyone let's
celebrate this great man and his a great
achievement achievement that we all
whether we like to admit it or not are
very thankful for today Godspeed